Prof: Now today I am
going to talk about biodiversity
and whether or not it's
something we should be worried
about,
and how to think about things
like the extinction crisis which
is being caused by human
activity.
And I don't want you to forget
this extremely simple idea here,
that the impact of humans on
the environment basically is a
function of how many people
there are on the planet,
times the average amount that
each of those people consumes,
multiplied perhaps by some
fudge factor to express good or
bad behavior on the part of the
humans.
And I think that the Greeks
probably could have written that
down 2500 years ago.
It's pretty straightforward.
It's nothing that is
particularly surprising.
Nevertheless it is striking to
me that this half of the
equation,
the upper half of the equation,
which is the population
problem,
has pretty much disappeared
from public discourse on this
issue,
and I think it's a result of
pushback from various groups
that see any discussion of the
population problem as inevitably
involving contraception or
abortion,
which for some groups has
religious issues.
And it's also a pushback from
the poor countries of the world,
against the rich countries,
saying,
"You can't come down here
and tell us what to do after
you've all gone and screwed up
your own environment.
Let us get on with our own
lives, and that's not our
priority."
Nevertheless,
in the long-term,
that's true.
The impact of humans on the
environment of the planet is
basically a function of how many
people there are on the planet
times how much they're using.
And we can't get away from that.
You will find in the literature
on things about biodiversity
problems, extinction problems,
an awful lot of fairly refined,
scientific analysis.
You will find people applying
cutting edge ecological theory
to the issue.
But, by way of introduction,
I never want you to forget that
the problem of human impact on
the other species on the planet
is not a problem that we can
really solve with scientific
research.
We can only solve it by
understanding the incentives
that people encounter to have
more babies,
or fewer babies,
and the incentives that they
encounter to consume more or to
consume less.
This is a really tough nut.
If any of you think this is
simple, just think of what's
going on in the global financial
crisis.
The people of the world are
trying to stimulate consumption.
They're desperate not to be
poor.
And that flies right in the
face of the environmental
catastrophe.
I don't think there's any easy
answer on that.
Yes Blake?
Student: People are
interested in
>.
Prof: Right,
Bob Wyman teaches a class on
population growth.
By the way, let me just take
one of Bob's slides,
which he shared with me
recently.
If you go around the planet and
you ask people how many babies
do they want,
good sociological research
indicates that they want about
two-thirds of what they actually
get.
And that suggests that the
easiest way to solve the
population problem is not to do
anything Draconian,
but just to give every woman on
the planet control of her own
reproductive fate;
by whatever means.
Okay, I just wanted to make
sure I got that message across
up front.
Now today I'm going to discuss
extinctions, and I am going to
do it from ecological,
economical, evolutionary and
personal points of view.
And within the ecological
literature this is an old
chestnut,
and basically back oh say about
thirty to fifty years ago there
was intuition that suggested
that the more diverse an
ecosystem was the more stable it
would be.
And people like stability,
they don't like to be hit by
surprises, and so diversity
would be good because it
conferred stability.
Then Bob May showed that more
diverse communities can be less
stable.
That's not a necessary logical
connection, that more diverse
things are more stable;
sometimes more diverse
communities are less stable.
Since then there have been a
lot of experiments.
There isn't a convincing clear
pattern.
More recent theory shows that
sometimes diversity can increase
stability.
This one seems to be a moving
target,
and I think it's one where we
have to be modest and say that,
"You know,
in any particular circumstance
we don't really know what would
happen."
Stability itself is a fairly
abstract term,
and it can either refer to
resistance,
which means ability to remain
in the same state,
or to resilience,
which means ability to return
to the same state following a
perturbation;
so bending without breaking.
And that is probably more
important in the real world.
Okay?
Now, what do we actually know
experimentally about what
species diversity does to
ecosystems?
Well there's some evidence,
by the way, that most of this
data has to do with plants,
or plants and insects.
A richer community appears
better able to survive a
drought.
That is probably because the
plants in interaction with each
other are actually conserving
water locally.
If you look at net primary
productivity,
as you increase the number of
plant species,
the productivity,
in terms of kilograms of carbon
fixed per square meter per year
goes up and then levels off;
so there's diminishing returns.
But the more different kinds of
things,
at least at the beginning,
that you pack into a given
space,
because they're partitioning
the environment differently the
more they're going to be able to
take out of the sunlight and the
C02 and the water that's in the
system,
and convert it into
biologically useful materials.
There's some evidence that as
you increase the number of
species in the community,
the harder it is for an
invasive species to get into
that community.
So these kinds of things are
done usually in fairly simple
experimental gardens.
And I think that the
application of that to the real
world I have to remain agnostic
on;
it might work, it might not.
Recently there was a very nice
paper--
this in the Proceedings of the
Royal Society this year--
showing that more diverse
pollinator communities provide
more reliable service.
So this X axis here is
proportion of native vegetation,
and this is the number of
pollinator individuals,
and this is again proportion of
native vegetation and number of
visits.
And basically what it's showing
is that the more diverse the
pollinator community,
the more likely it is that the
plants in it are going to get
pollinated,
because the different kinds of
pollinators are complementary,
they're trading services as
they come in.
And this connects a bit to
ecosystem function,
because after all one of the
things that Mother Nature gives
us in agriculture is the
services of the pollinators.
And if we didn't have them,
the almond industry and the
apple industry of the world
would collapse.
So if we do things that wipe
out the pollinator community,
or radically simplify it,
this paper suggests we can
expect that we're going to have
a decrease in our fruit and our
nut crops.
So a few ecological points
about diversity is that it does
seem to improve some ecosystem
properties.
There's some evidence that
connects species diversity to
resilience and to resistance to
invasion.
Not too many people who have
been working in the ecosystem
function end of science have
been terribly worried about the
diversity of individuals in
genes;
they've been looking mostly at
species diversity.
But it may very well be that if
you have say a group of
pollinators and you look within
a single species and you compare
very genetically diverse species
of pollinators with very
genetically homogenous species
of pollinators that the genetic
diversity may also have a
significant impact.
So there are a whole series of
levels at which one can ask the
diversity question,
and not all of them are equally
well researched.
Now let me just go back to the
ecological view of diversity
here and make a general comment
on it.
One of the arguments that
conservation advocates use is
that biodiversity is important
for ecosystem function.
And I'm now about to go into an
argument on ecosystem function.
Okay?
And it's about how much it's
going to cost us to replace
those services.
And I'm just setting a pointer
here,
because I'll come back in a few
minutes and point out that if
you claim that you need a lot of
biodiversity to maintain clean
air,
clean water,
pollination services,
everything that Nature gives us
for free,
but if Nature is really
redundant, so that you could
actually get rid of 90% of the
species on the earth before you
even noticed any decrease in
ecosystem function,
that you are then involving
yourself in a political argument
which is quite dangerous;
and that is that you appear not
to know what you're talking
about.
Because your critics could come
back year after year saying,
"Oh, we've lost another
10% of the species on the planet
and the ecosystems are still
functioning just fine.
You're just crying wolf."
Until, of course,
you get down to the point where
you've trimmed away so many that
the next ones really do make a
difference to ecosystem
function,
and then we're all in deep
water.
So there is a real problem here
of being able to communicate to
the general public,
and the politicians,
the issue that you could have a
lot of ecosystem redundancy,
which is buffering you from the
extinctions that might otherwise
be affecting ecosystem function,
but at some point,
if you've eliminated a lot of
species,
you will hit a limit at which
there's no redundancy left,
and at that point ecosystems
start to collapse.
So let's now go through the
economic argument,
and you'll see how much it
might cost to replace things.
So there have been attempts,
mainly by Bob Costanza and his
group--
he's now at the University of
Vermont--
to estimate what is the value
of ecosystem function.
And before we get into
Costanza's, we can look at
something like Habitat II.
So Ed Bass decides twenty years
ago or so to build a very
futuristic architectural piece
out in the Arizona desert,
which is an attempt to see
whether or not you could
actually build an interstellar
spacecraft with a self-enclosed,
completely recycling ecosystem,
such that people could go in it
and there would be everything in
it that people would need to
live forever.
So if you just make one of
those things and put it out into
space, potentially humans could
colonize other galaxies.
It's a very bold idea, right?
So it costs 9 million per
person, and if we wanted to
replace the earth with that,
you could figure that it's
about 54 thousand-trillion to
replace- to support everybody on
earth,
to get them to another galaxy.
Unfortunately Habitat II didn't
work.
>
So it wasn't complete,
and the people who went in it
and tried to live in it had to
bail out after about six months.
So this line of reasoning,
which by the way is always
going to end up with very big
numbers, is basically a comment
on externalization;
and externalization is
economics talk for things which
are not my problem,
thank you.
So they are basically what we
define,
in our approach to the problem,
as being outside the scope of
the problem and outside the
scope of our ability to come up
with a solution.
And I think you'll see that
some of these things need to be
internalized.
So the issue of externalization
is that in economics it means
it's not captured by the market.
So it's not something whose
consequences,
whose costs,
are reckoned into market
calculations.
So what Costanza and his crew
did was they tried to calculate
the marginal value of ecosystem
services,
and they just took the present
value of the service and then
asked,
"If we just tweak it a
little bit,
how much is it going to cost us
to replace--
just looking at the current
situation,
if we try to calculate the
replacement cost by tweaking
that service so that Mother
Nature doesn't provide it,
we have to replace it,
how much is it going to cost
us?"
Well they have a lot of numbers
in their paper,
and I'll just run through some
of them.
This is not--I don't really
expect you to memorize which
ecosystem service costs more to
replace.
But I think it is notable that
fertilizer in nutrient cycling,
keeping all of the plants on
the planet well fed,
is something that Mother Nature
does for us that would cost 17
trillion to replace.
It's interesting;
I heard Ed Wilson in Washington
a couple of weeks ago,
and he was talking about
figures like this,
and he said, "You know,
before this recovery plan,
the stimulus package,
I used to think that trillion
was a big number."
>
"And now it's a trillion
here, a trillion there;
after awhile you're talking
real money."
You can see the kinds of things
that people identify as
ecosystem services,
and certainly among them
nutrient cycling,
waste management,
water supply,
food,
the regulation of the
atmosphere, the regulation of
water on the landscape,
flooding and things like that,
those are all quite serious
things,
and Mother Nature is doing a
lot of that for us,
and she's never- she hasn't
been billing us for it lately.
And if you look at where this
is going on,
you'll find that the oceans are
actually doing about twice as
much as the land,
and the estuaries are providing
a tremendous amount of ecosystem
services,
and boy do people like to build
their houses on the water.
>
So if you just look at what
happened to the coast of the
Mediterranean or the coast of
Southeast Asia or the coast of
the Eastern Seaboard or Southern
California,
that is where people
concentrate their living.
They concentrate their living
right around estuaries;
Chesapeake Bay, for example.
And if you look at what are the
important parts of the
continental land masses,
the wetlands and the forests
are extremely important parts;
although you can't really say
that the grasslands are
unimportant, they're still
providing about a trillion a
year in ecosystem services.
So the marginal value,
back in 1997,
the marginal value of total
planetary ecosystem services was
about 33 trillion.
That was about four times the
U.S. GDP at that time.
Of course the U.S. GDP is
greater now, but I'll bet you
that the replacement costs for
what Nature gives us for free
are bigger now too.
So it's a big number.
And that's an estimate of how
much the global economy is
essentially externalizing the
costs of environmental impact,
and environmental services.
It's an estimate of the global
magnitude of the tragedy of the
commons,
which is that we all
individually want to take and
use services,
but our individual behavior is
eroding the environment for the
community.
And that is an estimate of to
what degree we're not connected
to the consequences of our own
actions,
and to what degree we're not
cleaning up our own messes.
So this economic view has been
criticized;
it's been criticized for bad
economics and it's been
criticized for bad ecology.
I actually think that it
retains an important take-home
message,
which is robust,
which is after you apply all
the criticisms and make all the
adjustments,
Mother Nature is still
providing us with goods and
services of enormous value,
which would be impossible for
us to replace if we had to.
I don't think there's any
getting around that.
One can argue about the
numbers, but I think the
take-home message remains solid.
Now to come back to my earlier
point about redundancy.
We could probably get by with a
lot fewer species.
And this was brought home to me
by my friend Pierre Henri
Gouyon,
who grew up in Central Paris,
in the cinquième
arrondissement,
in the middle of a fairly
artificial environment.
And basically he said,
"Listen,
we don't need ten million
species on the planet.
We only need 117.
We need cows, sheep and goats.
We need bacteria and fungi for
cheese, wine and beer.
And, in other words,
we only need the things that
will directly keep humans alive.
And if we need some to provide
these ecosystem services that
we've just gone through,
fine, maybe we need a few more,
but we don't need 10
million."
Now Pierre Henri actually is a
convinced environmentalist,
and he actually got fired from
his job for arguing with the
French government about
environmental problems.
He had a radio show in Paris,
and so he has been relegated to
the Natural History Museum in
Paris, which is a repository of
biodiversity.
But this is--he made this
argument in order to drive home
the point that there's a lot of
loose thinking that goes on
about ecosystem function and
redundancy,
and maybe it's good to have a
starting point from which you
can argue upwards.
Because once you decide that
you're going to base your
arguments for preserving species
on practical grounds,
and you're going to use
economic terms to argue for
them,
then you have to back it up
with data,
and you have to back it up with
well established facts.
And by starting with just 117,
I think that you are forced to
confront a number of pretty
serious issues in trying to make
those arguments.
So that's the economic view.
What would an evolutionary
biologist say?
Well basically it's pretty
clear that every tip on the Tree
of Life has been on the planet
for 3.5 billion years,
and they've all managed to make
it this far.
Good job.
It doesn't mean one's better
than the other,
they've all made it.
And if we just think about
relationship,
we have shared ancestors with-
we do share ancestors with all
life on the planet,
with the possible exception of
those nasty viruses that have
been so much with us this
winter,
and which are causing coughing
in the audience.
And you can go back and you can
find relationships with
virtually everything on the
planet;
just deeper and deeper in time.
And if you think about it,
and you go back on the Tree of
Life,
there you are,
maybe 3 billion years ago,
and the archaea are going off
in this direction and the
eukaryota are going off in that
direction;
or you go back 15 million years
and the Old World monkeys are
going this way,
and the hominidae are going
that way.
Or you go back 7 million years
and the chimpanzees go that way
and homo goes off in this other
direction.
Basically if you're looking it
as an evolutionary biologist,
okay, some chunk of DNA went
one way and some chunk of DNA
went the other,
down this branch,
and they both managed to make
it to this point,
but you can't really derive any
kind of morality about who has
the right to dominate and who
has the right to take over the
resources of the world from
that.
It's just a neutral pattern,
it's out there.
Okay?
So from that point of view,
looking at human culture is
kind of interesting,
because it's pretty late in the
game of evolution that humans
come up with this idea of
dominating.
And we are the winners.
Okay?
Actually this is quote from my
younger son: Winners write
history, losers write
novels.
The losers, who are the other
species on the planet,
pretty much have to accommodate
to the winners,
who are us, and who are
dominating the planet.
And if you think about what
we've done to them:
if you think about say 25% of
the birds going extinct in the
Pacific;
if you think about the fact
that current levels of
extinction during the
anthropogenic extinction crisis
are running at about 100 to 1000
times background rate;
if you think about the fact
that the total impact of human
civilization on the planet is
getting up to the point where
it's approaching that of a big
meteorite hitting the Yucatan,
then I think that it's probably
justified to use a phrase like
the greatest crimes.
Okay, this isn't Zhuang Zi,
whom I really like.
But basically what we've done
is we've driven to extinction,
and are driving to extinction,
many of the other occupants of
the planet.
And because it is increasing
our quality of life,
and our gross domestic
products, and our gross
planetary product,
it gets spun as being necessary
for standard of living and
economic growth.
So that would be an
evolutionary point of view.
Or let's say an evolutionary
biologist who loved plants and
animals would probably take that
rather cynical look at the whole
impact of human culture and
history on the planet.
Now to be fair to us--you know,
that's a fairly hard look at
us--
but to be fair to us,
I think if any other species
evolved to be dominant,
it probably would behave pretty
much the same way,
because it would have gotten
into that position by having a
motivational structure that made
it competitive and caused it to
be very efficient at extracting
and using resources.
And if we can ever actually
behave nicely to other species,
then I think that that would be
a profound victory of culture
over biology.
If you want to use a kin
selection argument,
don't hold your breath on this
one,
because we haven't yet
demonstrated that we can behave
nicely to other human beings;
and they're much more closely
related to us than other
species.
So I hope by this point you're
realizing that the extinction
crisis,
and the meaning of biodiversity
on the planet,
is an interesting probe into
our own nature and our own
priorities.
And in struggling with it there
will be many points at which one
could become pessimistic or
cynical,
but in fact I think you can
look at it as an opportunity to
learn an awful lot about
ourselves and about the Nature
that we interact with.
So it's not all pessimistic.
It's simply a very
deep-cutting,
revealing situation.
Now the personal point of view,
it was captured in this book
that my wife and I wrote,
and I'd like to tell you a
little bit about why we wrote it
and the sort of lessons that
we've learned from it.
So that's the name of the book,
and this picture is in it.
These are two Swiss hunters in
Southern Switzerland,
and this is the last bear that
was ever found in Switzerland.
They shot it in 1905.
And this kind of thing,
by the way, is now going on
again in Idaho and Montana.
The Department of the Interior
has just lifted the ban on
killing wolves.
There are about 800 wolves in
Idaho and Montana,
and they're getting shot at
again.
So this sort of thing is the
way people behave.
These guys were very proud of
the fact that they'd gotten a
bear.
So why did we write the book?
Well when I was--back in 1987,
I was asked by the Swiss
Government to comment on a
whitepaper that had been written
by an office in Washington,
which had been set up by
Congress to survey developments
in science,
and make recommendations to
Congress on whether or not
things were serious and needed
action.
And Peter Raven and Ed Wilson
had managed to move the
biodiversity crisis up to a
fairly high level,
and this office had taken
attention of it and had written
a whitepaper,
and the Swiss Government asked
me and my group to evaluate this
whitepaper.
As a result of that,
at the time that the European
Union decided to do something
about it,
I was invited as Switzerland's
representative,
to come to this meeting,
which John Lawton had arranged.
And it was held in England,
and at the meeting I was asked
to write a cover letter to our
report, which was going to go to
the European Commission.
Okay?
And I'm going to read a few
sections out of that,
because this is actually what
got me to write the book.
So, "The causes of
biodiversity crisis aren't in
Nature, they're in human
economic and reproductive
behaviors."
So it's right there.
"And biological research
isn't going to change human
behavior.
Human behavior can only be
changed by education,
economic, demographic policy,
and by shared values that
determine policy."
Okay?
At least shared values in a
democracy;
we were in European democracies.
"The long-term solution
requires a reduction in
birthrates and radical changes
in consumption.
However, starving,
insecure and repressed people
kill each other,
they destroy the environment,
they drive species to
extinction."
We certainly saw that in the
wars in the Congo where the
poachers were going through the
gorilla reserves and chopping
them up for bush meat.
"So the political
challenge is to figure out a way
to make people comfortable,
secure and free.
And that is a necessary
precondition for long-term
biodiversity stability."
We can't wait to do that.
Okay?
We can't wait for political and
economic change before we begin
to protect ecosystems and save
species.
Because if we do,
there's not going to be much
left to save.
So we have to start enforcing
for the protection of Nature
now.
And then the punch line was
this;
and this was in a conference of
scientists.
Okay?
"Scientists often claim
they need more money for
research, and they'll accept it
if you make it available.
Politicians can avoid
unpleasant decisions by saying
that more research is
needed."
So there's kind of a nice way
that they can help each other
out here.
And, "The research must
not be used as an excuse for not
taking action.
Because we already know this:
there are too many people.
Some of them,
mostly in the developed world,
consume too much,
and both conditions must
change."
So I was just simply trying to
state that, simply and
straightforwardly.
The reactions were really kind
of interesting,
and they also tell you
something about the history of
Europe.
So Norway, Germany,
Switzerland and England were
for it, and France,
Italy, Portugal and Greece were
against it.
The French delegate felt it
would play into the hands of the
far right;
it would provide a
justification for deportation of
immigrants;
characterized my attitude as
eco-Nazi;
and, as usual,
whenever the French are pushed
into a corner and they want to
pull out a trump card,
a violation of the rights of
man.
Okay?
Which they wrote.
By the way, this French
delegate went on to become the
environmental head of UNESCO.
So that was his attitude.
And the Norwegians,
who are a remarkably
self-satisfied and luxurious
people, felt that it didn't go
far enough.
Okay?
So they wanted to see something
that was more revolutionary.
The Germans thought it was a
good statement.
The British felt it was okay.
The Dutch liked it.
So I came away from that kind
of shocked,
but also realizing that
humanity is having great
difficulty agreeing on its value
system,
with regards to biodiversity.
And if we disagree,
we can't make much progress.
Okay?
There's a lot of human value
systems.
Some people think extinctions
are bad;
just about anybody in this
department would,
because they love animals and
plants, and that's why they have
chosen this career.
Some people might say that
extinctions aren't important,
that really what we need to do
is have a healthy economy and
save all the poor people in the
world,
and provide health care for
that, and forget about Nature;
you know, that's a secondary
priority.
And other people might say that
extinctions might even be good.
You might wonder who that is.
Any person who owns private
property, on which an endangered
species has been discovered,
is motivated by the current
incentive structure of
U.S. Law to make sure that
that species goes extinct before
the Federal Government finds out
that it exists.
Because if the Federal
Government finds out that it
exists, their property is open
to condemnation proceedings,
and they lose it.
So I have friends who are
ranchers in Hawaii who think
exactly that way.
So, because of this,
there are lots of conflicts;
we can't reach agreement and we
don't agree in that.
So how do you change value
systems?
How do you get people to agree?
How do you shift balance?
And I thought at that point
that it might be good just to
show how people emotionally
react to the process of watching
a species go extinct.
And Bev and I got together.
And I had originally tried to
do this as a novel,
and I discovered that my
ability to write convincing
fiction had been totally
destroyed by twenty-five years
of writing scientific papers.
And so Bev, who's a journalist,
said, "Why don't we go and
interview people?"
She's a journalist and she
knows how to interview people.
And she's a remarkably
sympathetic personality.
I'm kind of,
you know, big and have a white
beard and whatnot,
but she's very sympathetic,
and boy can she get information
out of people.
And so we decided to try that.
And our first interviews were
with Christophe and Hedwig
Boesch about the chimpanzees in
the Ivory Coast that are going
extinct,
and they were very deeply
moving interviews.
We decided it was going to work.
So we wrote the book.
And I just want to take a
couple of examples out of the
book.
This is the 'Alala,
the Hawaiian crow.
And it was on the island of
Hawaii;
when I was young,
you could occasionally see a
juvenile flying in the northern
part of the island.
By the time we started looking
into it, in the 1990s,
there were only eleven crows
left;
they were down from 110 in the
wild.
And they had disappeared from
every ranch, except the one
ranch whose owner kept the
biologists off the ranch.
And basically what had been
going on is that the crows--this
is a skull of an 'Alala--the
crows had been encountering
incompetent people.
And the take-home from that
particular chapter is that
competent people are in short
supply.
So in order to try to save
them, the biologists had taken
more than a hundred eggs and
fledglings into captivity,
and they'd killed all of them;
not one survived.
And the owner of the ranch,
where they were still managing
to live,
Cynthia Salley,
she decided that she wasn't
going to let anybody on the
ranch who was not really
motivated to help save the crow,
and so she told the biologists
that if they were going to work
on her ranch,
they couldn't publish any of
the results;
and that immediately stopped
all activity.
>
So the biologists were
interested in their publications
as much as, or perhaps a little
more than, they were interested
in the crows.
And what happened--oh there was
a crazy incident.
U.S. Fish &
Game told Cynthia that she was
in violation of the Endangered
Species Act,
and so in order to save the
crow--remember,
they'd already killed a
hundred--they were going to come
in with a helicopter and net the
remaining crows out of the air.
Now they admitted that they
hadn't practiced on house
sparrows.
Okay?
And there are only eleven of
this species left in the world.
So the helicopters are going to
come in,
and a biologist,
hanging off the helicopter,
is going to net the crow out of
the air,
because Cynthia wouldn't allow
them onto her property.
Well at that point Cynthia
realized how crazy it was,
and went to the governor and
got the governor to intervene.
And a committee from the
National Academy of Sciences
came out,
got the Peregrine Foundation
involved from Idaho,
and some competent people
reassured Cynthia that they
would be able to deal with the
situation.
So they took some of the
remaining crows into captivity
and established a captive
breeding program that now
worked.
And in 1999,
in September,
Bev and I went up,
and we saw the aviary where the
baby crows were living.
And the last two--it was a
pair, a male and a female--the
last two wild crows were
outside;
they were sitting up in a tree,
looking at the baby crows in
the aviary.
Baby crows were making lots of
noise, as baby crows will,
and the adults had been drawn
to the noise.
Now it turns out that if you
are a baby crow,
and you don't have a wild
reared parent,
you don't have anybody to teach
you that you're supposed to shut
up by 7:00 in the morning.
And so every time they released
some of these captive reared
crows,
they talked a lot,
and they got noticed,
and they got eaten by the rare
and endangered Hawaiian hawk.
>
So there still are some captive
reared crows,
but they can't release them.
And so essentially this species
now exists in captivity;
it doesn't exist in the wild
anymore, it's gone extinct in
the wild.
The next story has to do with
economic and demographic
processes.
And this is a story from
Chinese history.
It was assembled by a Dutch
diplomat named van Gulik,
who among other things wrote
some nice mystery novels set in
China, set in Tang China.
And it's about white faced
gibbons.
So the white faced gibbon
currently exists in Southern
Vietnam and in Thailand.
At the beginning of written
Chinese history,
there were white faced gibbons
north of Beijing.
So it over-wintered in the
mountains, in the snow,
north of Beijing.
By the time of the Tang,
it had been--
by the time the Tang fell,
so say roughly 900 or 1000
A.D.,
had been pushed down to the
Yangtze,
and then since then it had been
pushed out of the country.
And it was a very important
symbol in poetry and painting.
The gibbon and the crane were
both symbols of longevity.
When a Taoist saint got old,
he was supposed to turn into a
gibbon and become immortal.
The male gibbons have a very
haunting cry,
and if you are a monk
meditating in a monastery on say
the banks of the Yangtze Gorge,
you could hear,
at 5:00 in the morning,
a gibbon fifteen kilometers
away, giving out its territorial
cry,
and for that it brought in all
of the magic and mystery of
Nature into their imagination.
So it became an important
cultural object.
Well, van Gulik made this map,
which basically--so this the
Huang Ho, the Yellow River;
this is the Yangtze here.
And it shows sightings of
gibbons, all labeled at
different times.
And basically by the end of the
nineteenth century they'd been
completely pushed out of China.
Now the interesting thing about
that is that in A.D.
170, in the later Han Dynasty,
a group of policy wonks come to
the emperor and say,
"Oh Emperor,
the gibbon is going extinct,
and it's a terrible thing."
And the emperor says,
"Yes, it is a very
important part of our culture,
we must preserve it.
I authorize the army to stop
the peasants from cutting down
the forests."
That is what was causing the
gibbon to go extinct;
it was habitat destruction.
And the habitat destruction was
driven by demography.
Poor farmers were having
babies, and they needed charcoal
to cook food to feed their
babies.
So for a year or two the army
went out and protected the
forests.
But then there was a
revolution, the Han Dynasty
fell, the central control
vanished, and the demographic
processes did not change.
There were still poor farmers
having babies,
and they still needed to feed
their babies,
and they still wanted charcoal.
So basically the forests of
China got cut down,
and the gibbon went extinct in
China.
And that happened nearly 2000
years ago.
You might want to ask yourself
whether that might not still be
going on.
Let's take a look at a more
recent case in a politically
stable nation,
our own.
And this has to do with the
Barton Springs Salamander.
Barton Springs--how many people
here know Barton Springs;
Austin, Texas.
Have you swum in Barton Springs?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: Yeah.
Barton Springs--people in
Austin love Barton Springs;
nice steady temperature,
middle of a hot summer,
jump into the springs.
It's nice and cool,
clean water flowing out of the
karst formation.
It's one of the big quality of
life issues in Austin.
Okay?
Well there's a little
salamander that lives in Barton
Springs,
and it was used,
together with the SOS,
or Save our Springs,
Alliance, as a method of trying
to preserve the springs,
and the area around it,
from development.
And the argument was with
Freeport-McMoRan,
and the Texas Republican Party.
Freeport-McMoRan is based in
Louisiana, and it's one of the
world's largest mining
companies.
It's a pretty cutthroat
enterprise.
These people have employed the
Indonesian Army to put down
revolts in the western part- in
West Irian Jaya,
the western part of New Guinea,
where they have big copper and
gold mines.
And they play hardball.
And they were behind a scheme
to put a city roughly the size
of San Francisco next to Austin,
on the area out of which the
water drains,
to go into Barton Springs.
And so the environmentalist
argument was,
"We need to save the
springs;
therefore we can't have the
city, which is going to just
completely destroy our quality
of life."
And inside the springs there
are about twenty more endemic
species;
actually, they've now found
another salamander in the
springs as well.
However, the U.S. Endangered
Species Act doesn't allow you to
use a legal argument to preserve
a species unless it's been
named.
And so David Hillis,
in 1991 I think,
named the salamander and
described it officially in the
scientific literature as
Eurycea s-o-s-orum,
for Save our Springs-orum.
Right?
And it's a cute little
salamander.
Here it is.
It's about two inches long.
And I've been in the springs
and I've seen him.
And the political response to
trying to get this species
listed was really massive.
So Kay Bailey-Hutchinson made
sure there weren't any listings
in the whole U.S.
for a year, so that the
salamander wouldn't be listed.
And Mark Kirkpatrick and his
then wife Barbara Mahler,
and Bill Bunch,
who's an environmental lawyer,
they used the Endangered
Species Act,
and finally they forced the
Secretary of Interior to list
the salamander.
It took four years,
and during that four-year
period there were no species
listed in all of North America.
This one little salamander was
holding the whole thing up,
for the whole continent.
So the development was blocked
temporarily.
By the way, if the development
had gone through,
it would have meant billions of
dollars.
It was big, big money.
But this kind of conflict never
ends.
We've been back in touch with
the people there recently.
We're trying to update this
story a bit.
They do have a successful
captive breeding program.
They have been able to limit
the development somewhat.
But the pressure is just not
going to go away.
The only way that the
salamander will ever survive in
the long-term is if committed
conservationists manage to stay
active.
Because the economic incentive
to develop is always there;
it's not going to go away
either.
So to summarize these different
points of view.
If you just take the scientific
point of view.
There are some advantages in
some experiments that show
biodiversity is a good thing,
but results are mixed,
and if you just review all of
the biodiversity stuff,
on ecosystem function,
you have to come away honestly
and say,
"Well, it's a mixed
bag."
The economic view is that the
services would be very costly to
replace, but how they depend on
diversity is not clear;
so that's because we don't know
the redundancy in the system and
we don't know when we hit the
critical point.
The evolutionary view is that
all living things are related,
but there isn't any natural
value in diversity.
The evolutionary or purely
scientific point of view would
be that there is no value in
Nature;
so, you know,
whether the planet's dead or
alive actually doesn't make any
difference.
If we then place a human value
on diversity,
for cultural reasons,
as we saw with the gibbons,
or in our own culture--every
one of you is probably sitting
in this class because you had a
nice experience with some kind
of biodiversity at some point.
Well basically what that does
is we are placing a human value
on something,
and we've won the battle,
and now our value system,
which is our own homo sapiens
value system of one kind or
another--
and you've seen there are
bunches of them--
is being placed on the rest of
the planet.
So some people spend to exploit
the planet;
some people spend to conserve
it.
So what is the origin and
justification of values?
This interesting case of the
biodiversity crisis causes us to
confront that rather deep and
personal question.
And when you encounter people
who are actively engaged in the
conservation movement and
environmentalism,
I think you actually have to
ask, "Are the values that
they're deploying really
something that is general and
that you can derive for all
people at all times,
or is it simply an expression
of their personal taste?"
I happen to love orchids and
porpoises and so forth.
Other people like to eat
porpoises.
>
We're both human beings.
So if you want to read further
on this--actually the one that I
really recommend that you read
is this book by E.H. Carr,
on international relations
between the two World Wars.
That's sort of a modern
Machiavelli,
or Thucydides,
that shows you how the nations
of the world actually behave
when they are faced with
decisions on deep matters;
they behave in a very,
very hardball way.
Okay, next time we go into
behavior.